okay so for today um
we're actually gonna take a bit of a
change of pace from what the last couple
of lectures or have been about and we're
going to focus much more on
linguistics and natural language
processing and so in particular
we're going to start looking at the
topic of dependency parsing
and so this is the plan of what to go
about through today so i'm going to
start out by going through some ideas
that have been used with the syntactic
structure of languages of constituency
and dependency and introduce those and
then focusing in more on
dependency structure i'm then going to
look at dependency grammars and
dependency tree banks and then having
done that we're then going to move back
into thinking about how to build natural
language processing systems and so i'm
going to introduce the idea of
transition based dependency parsing and
then in particular having developed that
idea i'm going to talk about a way to
build a simple but highly effective
neural dependency parser
and so this simple highly effective
neural dependency parser is essentially
what we'll be asking you to build um in
the third assignment so in some sense
we're getting a little bit ahead of
ourselves here because in week two of
the class um we teach you how to do both
assignments two and three um but all of
this material will come in really useful
before i get underway just a couple of
announcements
so
if
for a site again for assignment two you
don't yet need to use the pi torch
framework
but now's a good time to work on getting
pie torch installed for your python
programming
assignment three is in part also an
introduction to using pytorch it's got a
lot of scaffolding included in the
assignment um but beyond that um this
friday
we've got a pie torch tutorial and
thoroughly encourage you um to come
along to that as well look for it under
the zoom tab and um in the in the second
half of the thursday of week four we
have an explicit class that um partly
focuses on the final projects and what
the choices are for those but it's never
too late to start thinking about the
final project and what kind of things
you want to do for the final project um
so do um come meet with people there are
so resources on the course pages about
what different
tas know about i've also talked to a
number of people about final projects
but clearly i can't talk to everybody so
i encourage you to also be thinking
about what you want to do for final
projects
okay so what i wanted to do today
was introduce
how people think about the structure of
sentences um and to put structure on top
of them to explain how human language
conveys meaning
and so our starting point for meaning
and essentially what we've dealt with
with word vectors
up until now is we have words and words
are
obviously an important part of the
meaning of human languages but for words
in human languages um
there's more that we can do with them in
thinking about how to structure
sentences so in particular the first
most basic way that we think about words
when we
thinking about how sentences are
structured is we give to them what's
called a part of speech
we can say that cat is a noun
by is a preposition
door is another noun
cuddly is an adjective
and then for the word the
um if it was given a different part of
speech if you saw any parts of speech in
school it was probably you're told it
was an article
sometimes
that is just put into the class of
adjectives in modern linguistics and
what you'll see in the resources that we
use words like that are referred to as
determiners and the idea is that there's
a bunch of words includes art and
but also other words like this and that
um
or even
every which are words sort of occur at
the beginning
of something like the cuddly cat which
have a
determinative function of sort of
picking out which cats that they're
referring to and so we refer to those as
determiners
but it's not the case that when we want
to communicate with language that we
just have this word salad where we say a
bunch of words
we just say you know whatever
leaking kitchen tap and um let the other
person put it together we put words
together in a particular way to express
meanings and so therefore languages have
larger units of putting meaning together
and the question is how we represent and
think about those
now in modern
work um in particular in modern united
states linguistics or even what you see
in computer science classes when
thinking about formal languages the most
common way to approach this is with the
idea of context-free grammars which you
see at least a little bit of in 103 if
you've done 103 what a linguist would
often refer to as free structure
grammars and the idea there is to say
well there are bigger units in languages
that we refer to as phrases so something
like the cuddly cat is a cat um with
some other words modifying it and so
we'll refer to that as a noun phrase
um but then we have
ways in which phrases can
get larger um by building things and
side phrases so the door here is also a
noun phrase um but then we can build
something bigger around it with the
prepositions as a preposition and then
we have a prepositional phrase
and in general we can keep going so we
can then make something like the cuddly
cat by the door and then the door is a
noun phrase the cuddly cat is a noun
phrase
by the door as a prepositional phrase
but then when we put it all together the
whole of this thing becomes a bigger
noun phrase
and so it's working with these ideas of
nested phrases what in context-free
grammar terms you'd refer to as
non-terminals
so noun phrase and
prepositional phrase would be
non-terminals in the context-free
grammar we can build up a bigger
structure of human languages
so let's just do that for a little bit
um to review what happens here so we
start off saying okay you can say
the cat and the dog and so those are
noun phrases and so we want a rule that
can explain those so we could say a noun
phrase goes to determiner noun
and then somewhere over the side we'd
have a lexicon
and in our lexicon we'd say that dog is
a noun and cat is a noun
and
is a determiner and that is a determiner
okay so then we notice you can do a bit
more than that
so you can say things like the large cat
a barking dog
so that suggests we can have a noun
phrase
after the determiner
there can optionally be an adjective
and then there's the noun and that can
explain some things we can say but we
can also say the cat by the door
or a barking dog in a crate and so we
can also
put
a prepositional phrase at the end and
that's
optional but you can combine it together
with an adjective for the example i gave
like a barking dog on the table
and so that
this grammar can handle that
um so then we'll keep on and say
um well actually you can use multiple
adjectives so you can say a large
barking dog or
a large
barking cuddly cat no maybe not well
sentences like that so we have any
number of adjectives which we can
represent with a star what's referred to
as the cleany star
so that's good um
oh but i forgot a bit actually um for by
the door i have to have a rule for
producing by the door so i also need a
rule that's a prepositional phrase goes
to a preposition followed by a noun
phrase and so then i also have to have
prepositions and that can be in
or on
or by
okay and i can make other sentences of
course with this
as well like the large crate on the
table or something like that or the
large
crate on the large table
okay so i chug along
and then well i could have something
like talk to the cat and so now i need
more stuff so talk is a verb
and two is still looks like a
preposition
so i need to be able to make up
something um with that as well
okay so what i can do is say i can also
have a rule for a verb phrase that goes
to a verb
and then after that for something like
talk to the cat that it can take a
prepositional phrase after it and then i
can say that the verb goes to talk
or walked
um
okay then i can pause then i can cover
those sentences oops
um okay so that's that's the end of what
i have here um so in this sort of a way
i'm
hand writing a grammar so here is now i
have this grammar
and a lexicon
and for the examples that i've written
i've written down here um this grammar
and this lexicon
is sufficient um to pass these sort of
fragments of showing expansion that i
just wrote down i mean of course there's
a lot more to english than what you see
here right so if i have something like
you know the cat
walked
behind the dog
then i need some more grammar rules so
it seems then i need a rule that says i
can have a sentence that goes to a noun
phrase followed by a verb phrase um and
i can keep on um doing things of this
sort
um that's the um one question that um
ruthanne asked was about um what
the brackets mean
and is the first np different from the
second um
so for this notation on the brackets
here i mean this is actually a a common
notation that's used in linguistics um
it's sort of in some sense a little bit
different to traditional
computer science notation since the star
is used in both to mean zero or more of
something so you could have zero one two
three four five adjectives
somehow it's usual in linguistics that
when you're using the star you also put
parentheses around it um to mean it's
optional so sort of parentheses and star
are used together to mean any number of
something
when it's parentheses just by themselves
that's then meaning zero or one
um and then four
um
are these two noun phrases
different no they're both noun phrase
rules and so in our grammar we can have
multiple rules that expand noun phrase
in different ways um but
you know actually in my example here my
second rule because i wrote it quite
generally it actually covers the first
rule as well so actually at that point i
can cross out this first rule because i
don't actually need it in my grammar but
in general you know you haven't a choice
between writing multiple rules for noun
phrase goes to categories which
effectively gives you a disjunction or
working out by various syntactic
conventions how to compress them
together
okay
um so that was what gets referred to in
natural language processing as
constituency grammars um where the
standard form of constituency grammar is
a context free grammar of the sort that
i trust you saw at least a teeny bit of
either in cs 103 or something like a
programming languages compilers formal
languages class
there are other forms of grammars that
also pick out constituency
there are things like tria joining
grammars but i'm i'm not going to really
talk about any of those now what i
actually want to present is a somewhat
different way of looking at grammar
which is referred to as
um dependency grammar which puts a
dependency structure over sentences
now actually it's not that these two
ways of looking at grammar have nothing
to do with each other i mean there's a
whole um
formal theory about the relationships
between different kinds of grammars and
you can very precisely state
relationships um and
isomorphisms between different grammars
of different kinds but on the surface
these two kinds of grammars
look sort of different and emphasize
different things and
for
reasons
of this sort of closeness to picking out
relationships and sentences and their
ease of use it turns out
that in modern natural language
processing starting i guess around 2000
so really in the last 20 years
nlp people have really swung behind
dependency grammars so if you look
around now where people are using
grammars in nlp by far the most common
thing that's being used is dependency
grammars um so i'm going to teach us
today a bit about those and for what
we're going to build um in
assignment three is building
using supervised learning and neural
dependency parser
so the idea of dependency grammar is
that when we have a sentence
what we're going to do
is we're going to say for each word what
other words um modify it
so what we're going to do is when we say
the large crate we're going to say okay
well large is modifying crate and that
is modifying crate
in the kitchen that is modifying kitchen
by the door that is modifying door and
so i'm showing a modification that
depends a dependency or an attachment
relationship by drawing an arrow from
the head to what's referred to in
dependency grammar as the dependent
the thing that modifies further
specifies or attaches
to the head
um
okay so that's the start of this um well
another dependency um that is that well
um in
look in the large crate
that where you're looking is in the
large crate so you're going to want to
have the large in the large crate as
being a dependent of look and so that's
also going to be a dependency
relationship here
um and then there's one final bit um
that might
seem a little bit confusing to people
and that's actually when we have these
prepositions um there are two ways that
you can
think that this might work so if it was
something like
look
in the crate
it seems like that is a dependent of
crate but you could think that you want
to say look in
and it's in the crate and give this
dependency relationship with the sort of
preposition
as sort of thinking of it as the head of
what was before our prepositional phrase
and that's a possible strategy in the
dependency grammar
but
what i'm going to show you today
and what you're going to use in the
assignment
is dependency grammars that follow the
representation of universal dependencies
and universal dependencies is a
framework which actually is involved in
creating which was set up to try and
give a common dependency grammar over
many different human languages and in
the design decisions that were made in
the context of designing
universal dependencies
what we decided was that
for what in some languages you use
prepositions
lots of other languages make much more
use of case markings so
if you've seen something like german
you've seen more case markings
like genitive and dative cases and in
other languages like latin or finnish
lots of native american languages you
have many more case markings again which
cover most of the role of prepositions
um so in universal dependencies
essentially in the crate is treated like
a case marked noun and so what we say is
that the in is also a dependent of crate
and then you're looking in the crate um
so
in the structure we adopt um
in as a dependent of crate this inn is a
dependent of kitchen
this buy is a dependent of door
and then we have these prepositional
phrases in the kitchen by the door and
we want to work out well what they
modify
well
in the kitchen is modifying crate right
because it's a crate in the kitchen so
we're going to say that it's
this piece is a dependent of crate
um and then
well what about by the door
well it's not really meaning that's a
kitchen by the door
um and it's not meaning to look by the
door
again it's a crate by the door and so
what we're going to have is the crate
also has door as a dependent and so that
gives us our full dependency structure
of this sentence
okay
and so that's
a teeny introduction to syntactic
structure i'm going to say a bit more
about it and give a few more examples
but let me just for a moment sort of say
a little bit about well why are we
interested in syntactic structure why do
we need to know the structure of
sentences
and this gets into
how does human languages work so
human
languages can
can
communicate very complex ideas i mean in
fact you know anything that humans know
how to communicate to one another they
communicate pretty much by using words
so we can structure and communicate very
complex ideas but we can't
um communicate a really complex idea
by one word we can't just you know
choose a word like
you know empathy and say it with a lot
of meaning and say empathy and the other
person is meant to understand everything
about what that means right we have to
compose a complex meaning that explains
things by putting words together into
bigger units and the syntax of a
language allows us to put words together
into bigger units um where we can build
up and convey to other people a complex
meaning
and so then the listener doesn't get
this syntactic structure right the
syntactic structure of the sentence is
hidden from the listener all the
listener gets is a sequence of words one
after another bang bang bang so the
listener has to be able to do what i was
just trying to do in this example that
as the sequence of words comes in
that the listener works out which words
modify which other words and therefore
can construct the structure of the
sentence and hence
the meaning of the sentence
and so in the same way
if we want to build clever neural net
models that can understand the meaning
of sentences those clever neural net
models also have to understand what is
this structure of the sentence so that
they can interpret the language
correctly and we'll go through some
examples and see more of that
okay so the fundamental point that we're
going to sort of
spend a bit more time on is
that
these choices of how you build up the
structure of a language
change the interpretation of the
language and a human
listener or equally a natural language
understanding program
has to make in a sort of probabilistic
fashion
choices as to which words modify i
depend upon which other words so that
they're coming up with the
interpretation of the sentence that they
think was intended by the person who
said it okay so um
to get a sense of this and how sentence
structure
is um interesting and difficult what i'm
going to go through now is a few
examples of different ambiguities that
you find in natural language
and i've got some funny examples some
newspaper headlines but these are all
real
natural language ambiguities that you
find throughout um
natural language well at this point i
should say
this is where i'm being guilty of saying
language but i'm meaning in english
some of these ambiguities you find in
lots of other languages as well but
which ambiguities for syntactic
structure
partly depend on the details of the
language so different languages have
different syntactic instructions
different word orders different amounts
of
word having different forms of words
like case markings and so depending on
those details there might be different
ambiguities so here's
one ambiguity which is one of the
commonest ambiguities in english so san
jose cops kill man with knife so this
sentence has two meanings um either it's
the san jose cops um who are killing a
man and they're killing a man with a
knife um and so that corresponds to a
dependency structure where the san jose
cops are the subject of killing the man
is the object of killing
and then
the knife is then the instrument with
which they're doing the killing so that
the knife is an oblique modifier for the
instrument of killing and so that's one
possible structure for this sentence um
but it's probably not the right one um
so what it actually probably was was
that it was a man with a knife and the
san jose cops killed the man so that
corresponds to the knife
then being a noun modifier
of the man and then kill is still
killing the man so the man is the object
of killing and the cops are still the
subject
and so whenever you have
a prepositional phrase like this that's
coming further on in a sentence
there's a choice of how to interpret it
it could be either interpreted as
modifying a noun phrase that comes
before it or it can be
interpreted as modifying a verb that
comes before it so systematically in
english you get these prepositional
phrase attachment ambiguities throughout
all of our sentences
but
um you know to give two further
observations on that you know the first
observation is
you know
you encounter sentences
um with prepositional phrase attachment
um
ambiguities every time you read a
newspaper article every time you talk to
somebody but most of the time you never
notice them and that's because our human
brains are incredibly good at
considering the possible interpretations
and going with the one that makes sense
according to context
the second comment as i said different
human languages
expose different ambiguities so for
example this is an ambiguity that you
normally don't get in chinese because in
chinese
prepositional phrases modifying a verb
are normally placed before the verb and
so therefore you don't standardly
get this ambiguity but you know
there are different other ambiguities
that you find commonly in chinese
sentences
okay so this ambiguity you find
everywhere because prepositional phrases
are really common at the right ends of
sentences
so here's another one um scientists
count whales from space
so
that gives us these two possible
interpretations that there are whales
from space
and scientists are counting them um and
then the other one is
how the scientists are counting the
whales is that they're counting them
from space and they're using satellites
to count the sales which is the correct
interpretation um that
the newspaper
hopes that you're getting
um
and this problem gets much much more
complex because
many sentences
in english have prepositional phrases
all over the place um so here's the kind
of boring sentence
that you find in the financial you news
the board approved its acquisition by
royal trusco limited of toronto for 27
dollars a share at its monthly meeting
and well if you look at the structure of
this sentence what we find is you know
here's a verb then here's the object
noun phrase
so we've got the object noun phrase here
and then after that what do we find well
we find a prepositional phrase another
prepositional phrase another
prepositional phrase and another
prepositional phrase and how to attach
each of these is then ambiguous so the
basic rule of how you can attach them is
you can attach them to things to the
left
providing you don't create crossing
attachments so in principle
by royal trusco limited could be
attached to either approved or
acquisition but in this case
by royal trusco limited is that it's the
acquirer so it's
um
a
modifier
of the acquisition
okay so then we have of toronto so of
toronto could be modifying raw trusco
limited it could be modifying the
acquisition or it can be modifying the
approved and in this case the of toronto
is telling you more about the company
and so it's a modifier of royal trusco
limited
okay so then the next one is for 27 a
share
and that could be modifying toronto
royal trusca limited the acquisition or
the approving
and well
in this case um
that's talking about the price of the
acquisition
so this one is mod go jumps back and
this is now a prepositional phrase
that's modifying the acquisition
and then at the end at its um monthly
meeting um well that's where the
approval is happening um by the ver by
the board so rather than any of these
preceding four noun phrases
at its monthly meeting is modifying the
approval um and so it attaches right
back there and this example is kind of
too big and so i couldn't fit it in one
line but as i think maybe you can see
that you know none of these dependencies
cross each other
and they connect at different places
ambiguously
so because we can chain these
prepositions like this and attach them
at different places like this um human
language sentences are actually
extremely ambiguous
um
so the number if you have a sentence
with um k
prepositional phrases um at the end of
it where here we have k equals four um
the number of parses this sentence has
the number of different ways you can
make these attachments is given by the
catalan numbers so the catalan numbers
are an exponentially
growing series which arises in many
tree-like contexts so if you're doing
something like triangulations of a
polygon you get catalan numbers if
you're
doing triangulation and graphical models
in cs228 you get catalan numbers but we
don't need to worry about the details
here the central point is this is an
exponential series and so you're getting
an exponential number of parsers in
terms of the number of prepositional
phrases um and so in general you know
the number of parsers human languages
have is exponential in their length
which is kind of bad news um because if
you're then trying to enumerate all the
parsers it you might fear that you
really have to do a ton of work
the thing to notice about structures
like these prepositional phrase
attachment ambiguities is that there's
nothing that resolves these ambiguities
in terms of the structure of the
sentence
so
if you've done something like looked at
the kind of grammars that are used in
compilers that the grammars used in
compiling compilers for programming
languages are mainly made to be
unambiguous and to the extent that there
are any
ambiguities there are default rules that
are used to say choose this one
particular
parse tree
for your piece of a programming language
and human languages just aren't like
that they're globally ambiguous and the
listening human is just meant to be
smart enough to figure out what was
intended so the analogy
would be that you know in programming
languages um when you're working out
what does an else clause modify
well
you've got the answer that you can
either look at um the curly braces to
work out what the else clause modifies
or if you're using python you look at
the indentation and it tells you what
the else clause modifies where by
contrast for human languages
um the it would be
um just write down else something
it doesn't matter how you do it you
don't need parentheses you don't need
indentation the human being will just
figure out what the else clause is meant
to pair up with
okay lots of other forms of ambiguities
in human languages so let's look at a
few others
another one that's very common over all
sorts of languages is coordination scope
ambiguities
so here's a sentence shuttle veteran and
long time nasa executive fred gregory
appointed the board
well this is an ambiguous sentence um
there are two possible readings of this
one reading is that there are two people
there's a shuttle veteran and there's a
long time nasa executive fred gregory
and they were both appointed to the
board two people
and the other possibility is there's
um someone named fred gregory who's a
shuttle
veteran and long-time lesser executive
and they're appointed to the verb one
person
and these two interpretations again
correspond to having different path
structures
so in one structure
we've got a coordination of the shuttle
veteran and the long time nasa executive
fred gregory coordinated together
in one case these are coordinated and
then fred gregory specifies the name of
the nasa executive um
so it's then um
specifying um who that executive is
where the what in the other one the
shuttle veteran and long time nasa
executive all together is then something
that is a modifier of um
fred gregory
okay so one time this is the unit that
modifies fred gregory in the other one
up here just long time nasa executive
modifies fred gregory and then that's
conjoined together with the shuttle
veteran
and so that also gives different
interpretations um so this is a slightly
reduced example of the i mean in
um
newspaper headlines tend to be more
ambiguous
than many other pieces of text because
they're written in this shortened form
to get things to fit
and this is an especially shortened form
where it's actually left out in the
explicit conjunction
but this headline
says doctor no heart cognitive issues
and this was after i guess one of trump
it was after trump's first physical and
while this was an ambiguity because
there are two ways that you can read
this you can either read this as saying
doctor no heart and cognitive issues
which gives you one interpretation
instead of that the way we should read
it um is
that it's
heart
or cognitive
and so then saying no
heart or cognitive issues
and we have a different
narrower scope of the coordination and
then we get a different reading
okay um
i want to give a couple more examples of
different kinds of
ambiguities another one you see quite a
bit is when you have modifiers that are
adjectives and adverbs um that there are
different ways that you can have things
modifying other things um this example
is a little bit not safe for work but
here goes
students get first-hand job experience
so this is an ambiguous sentence and
again we can think of it as a syntactic
ambiguity in terms of
which things modify which other things
so
the nice
polite way to
render this sentence
is that
first is modifying hands so we've got
first hand um it's job experience so job
is a compound noun modifying experience
and it's first-hand experience
so ex
first hand is then modifying experience
and then get is the object of
sorry first-hand job experience is the
object of get and
the students are the subject of get
but if you have a smuttier mind
you can interpret this a different way
and in the
alternative interpretation
you then have
hand going together with job um
and
the
the first is then a modifier of
experience
um and job is still a modifier of
experience and so then you get this
different path structure and different
interpretation there
okay one more example
in a way this example is similar to the
previous one
it's sort of having
modifier pieces that can modify
different things but rather than just
being with individual adjectives or
individual adverbs is then much larger
units
such as verb phrases can often have
attachment ambiguities so this sentence
headline is mutilated body washes up on
rio beach to be used for olympic speech
volleyball
so we have this big verb phrase here of
to be used for olympics beach volleyball
and then again we have this attachment
decision um
that we could either say
um
that
that big verb phrase is
modifying i
is attached to
the rio beach
or
um we could say no no the to be used for
olympic speech body
volleyball
that that
is
modifying the mutilated body and it's a
body
that's to be used for the olympic speech
volleyball
um which gives the funny reading yeah so
i hope that's given you at least a
little bit of a sense of how
human language syntactic structure is
complex
ambiguous and to work out the intended
interpretations you need to know
something about that structure
in terms of how much you
need to understand i mean you know this
isn't a linguistics class if you'd like
to learn more about human language
structure you can go off and do a syntax
class
but you know
we're not really going to spend a lot of
time working through language structure
but there will be some questions on this
in the assignment and so we're expecting
that you can be at the level that you
can have sort of some intuitions as to
which words and phrases are modifying
other words and phrases and therefore
you could choose between two dependency
analyses which one's correct
okay um i've spent quite a bit of time
on that um so better um keep going okay
so
the general idea is that knowing
this sort of syntactic structure of a
sentence can help us with semantic
interpretation
i mean as well as just generally saying
we can understand language it's also
used in many cases for simple practical
forms of semantic extraction so people
such as in biomedical informatics often
want to get out particular relations
such as protein protein interactions and
well here's a sentence the results
demonstrated that chi c interacts
rhythmically with
sas a
chi a and kai b
um and commonly that people can get out
those kind of relationships by looking
at patterns of dependency relations with
particular verbs so for the interacts
verb if you have a pattern of something
being the subject and something else
being the noun modifier of interacts
well that's an interaction relationship
but it gets a bit more complicated than
that as in this example because often
there are conjunctions so you also want
to have another pattern where you have
also interactions between the subject
and the noun modifiers conjunct which
will allow us to also find the chi a and
kb examples
okay um
so i've sort of given an informal tour
of dependency grammar to just try and uh
quickly
say a little bit more about formally
what a dependency grammar is so in
dependency syntax what we say is that
the syntactic structure of a sentence
consists of relations between pairs of
words
and it's a binary asymmetric relation i
we draw arrows between pairs of words
which we call dependencies
now normally dependency grammars then
type those grammatical relation type
those arrows to express what kind of
relation that there is and so that they
have some kind of taxonomy of
grammatical relation so we might have a
subject grammatical relation a verbal
auxiliary grammatical relation an
oblique modifier grammatical relation we
have some kind of typology of
grammatical relations
so and we refer to the arrow as going
between the head
is the head here and something that is a
dependent of it so the subject of a verb
is the dependent of the verb or when you
have a noun modifier like our sort of
cuddly cat
we say that um
cuddly is a dependent of cat and so cat
is the head of cuddly cat
and so normally
dependencies like in these examples form
a tree
which is formal it so it's not just any
graph with arrows we have an
and graph which is connected a cyclic
and has a single root so here's the root
of the graph
and so that gives us a dependency tree
analysis
dependency grammars have a really really
long history
so the famous first linguist um was
panini um who wrote about the
structure of sanskrit um and mainly he
worked on the sound system of sanskrit
and how sounds change in various
contexts which what linguists call
phonology and the different forms of
sanskrit words sanskrit has rich
morphology of inflecting nouns and verbs
for different cases and forms
but he also worked a little on the
syntactic structure of sanskrit
sentences and essentially what he
proposed was a dependency grammar over
sanskrit sentences
and it turns out that sort of for most
of recorded history when then when
people have then um gone on and tried to
put structures over human sentences um
what they have used is dependency
grammars um so there was a lot of work
in the first millennium by arabic
grammarians of trying to work out the
grammar um the structure of sentences
and effectively what they used was
you know akinned what i've just
presented as a dependency grammar so
compared to you know 2500
years of history the ideas of having
context-free grammars and having
constituency grammars is actually a
really really recent invention so it was
really sort of in the middle of the 20th
century that the ideas of um
constituency grammar and context free
grammars were developed first by wells
in the 40s and then by noam chomsky in
the early 50s leading to things like the
chomsky hierarchy that you might see um
cs103 or a formal languages class
um
so for modern work on dependency grammar
using kind of the terminology and um
notation that i've just introduced
that's normally attributed to
lucianteniere who was a french linguist
um in around the sort of middle of the
20th century as well
dependency grammar was widely used in
the 20th century um in a number of
places i mean in particular it tends to
be sort of much more natural and easier
to think about for languages that have a
lot of different case markings or nouns
like nominative accusative genitive data
of instrumental kind of cases like you
get in a language like latin or russian
and a lot of those languages have much
freer word order than english so the
subject or object of you know in english
the subject has to be before the verb
the object has to be after the verb but
lots of other languages have much freer
word order and instead use different
forms of nouns to show you what's the
subject or the object of the sentence
and dependency grammars can often seem
much more natural for those kinds of
languages
dependency grammars were also prominent
at the very beginnings of computational
linguistics so
one of
the first people working computational
linguistics in the us
was david hayes so the professional
society for computational linguistics is
called the association for computational
linguistics and he was actually one of
the founders of the association for
computational linguistics and he
published in the early 1960s um an early
perhaps the first dependency
grammar
paused sorry dependency parser
okay
um
yeah a little teeny note just in case
you see other things when when you have
these arrows um you can draw them in
either direction you can either draw
arrows from the head or to the dependent
or from the dependent to the head and
actually different people have done one
and the other right so the way tenure
drew them was to draw them from the head
to the dependent and we're following
that convention but you know if you're
looking at something that somebody else
has written um with dependency arrows
the first thing you have to work out is
are they using the arrow heads at the
heads or the dependents um now and not
one other thing here is that
we
a sentence is seen as having the overall
head word of the sentence which every
other word of the sentence hangs off
it's a common convention to add this
sort of fake root to every sentence that
then points um to the head word of the
whole sentence here completed
that just tends to make the algorithmic
stuff easier because then you can say
that every word of the sentence is
dependent on precisely one other node
where what you can be dependent on is
either another word on the sentence or
the fake root of the sentence and when
we build our parsers we will introduce
that fake root
okay
so
um that's sort of dependency grammars
and dependency structure i now want to
get us back
to
natural language processing and starting
to build parses for dependency grammars
but
before doing that i just want to say
yeah
where do we get our data from and that's
actually an interesting story in some
sense
so
the answer to that is
well
what we do
is get
human beings commonly linguists or other
people who are actually interested in
the structure of human sentences
and we get them to sit around and hand
pass sentences and give them dependency
structures
and we collect a lot of those
parsers and we call that a tree bank
and so um this is
something that really only started
happening in the late 80s and took off
in a bigger way in the 90s until then no
one had attempted to build tree banks
lots of people had attempted to build
parsers and it seemed like well if you
want to build a parser the efficient way
to do it is to start writing a grammar
so you start writing some grammar rules
and you start writing a lexicon with
words and parts of speech and you sit
around working on your grammar
when i was a phd student one of my first
summer jobs was spending the summer
handwriting a grammar
and
it sort of seems like writing a grammar
is more efficient because you're writing
this one general thing that tells you
the structure of a human language um but
there's just been this massive sea
change partly driven by the adoption of
machine learning techniques
where it's now seen as axiomatic that
the way to make progress is to have
annotated data namely here a tree bank
that shows you the structure of
sentences and so what i'm showing here
is a teeny extract um from a universal
dependencies tree bank and so that's
what i mentioned earlier that this has
been
this effort to try and have a common
dependency grammar representation that
you can apply to lots of different human
languages and so you can go over to this
url and see that there's about 60
different languages at the moment which
have universal dependencies tree banks
um so why are tree banks good i mean
it sort of seems like it's bad news if
you have to have people
sitting around for weeks and months hand
passing sentences it seems a lot slower
and actually a lot less useful
than
having somebody writing a grammar which
just has um you know a much bigger
multiplier factor in the utility of
their effort
it turns out
that although that feel initial feeling
seems sort of valid that in practice
there's just a lot more you can do with
the tree bank so why are tree banks
um great you know one
reason is the tree banks are highly
reusable so typically when people have
written grammars they've written
grammars for you know one particular
parser and the only thing it was ever
used in is that one particular parser
but when you build a tree bank
that's
just a use a useful data resource and
people use it for all kinds of things so
the well-known tree banks have been used
by hundreds and hundreds of people and
although
all tree banks were initially built for
the purposes of hey let's help natural
language processing systems it turns out
that people have actually been able to
do lots of other things with tree banks
so for example these days
psycholinguists commonly use tree banks
to get various kinds of statistics about
data for thinking about psycholinguistic
models linguists use tree banks for
looking at patterns of different
syntactic constructions that occur um
that there's just been a lot of reuse of
this data
for all kinds of purposes but they have
other advantages that i mentioned here
you know when people are just sitting
around saying oh what sentences are good
they tend to only think of the core of
language where lots of weird things
happen in language and so if you
actually just have some sentences and
you have to go off and pass them then
you actually have to deal with the
totality of language um since you're
parsing actual sentences you get
statistics so you naturally get the kind
of statistics that are useful to
machine learning systems by constructing
a tree bank
where you don't get them for free if you
hand write a grammar but then a final
way
which is perhaps the most important of
all
is
you if you actually want to
be able to do
um
science of building systems you need a
way to evaluate these nlp systems i mean
it seems hard to believe now that you
know back in the
90s
and 80s when people built nlp parsers it
was literally the case
um that the way they were evaluated was
you said to your friend oh i've built
this parser type in a sentence on the
terminal and see what it gives you back
it's pretty good hey um and that was
just the way business was done
um whereas what we'd like to know is
well as i showed you earlier english
sentences can have lots of different
parsers commonly can this
system choose the right parses for
particular sentences and therefore have
the basis of
interpreting them as a human being would
and while we can only systematically do
that evaluation if we have a whole bunch
of sentences that have been hand passed
by humans with their correct
interpretations
so the rise of tree banks turned parser
building into an empirical science where
people could then compete rigorously on
the basis of look my parser has two
percent higher accuracy than your parser
in choosing the correct parsers for
sentences
okay so well how do we build a parser
once we've got dependencies so there's
sort of a bunch of sources of
information that you could hope to use
so one source of information
is looking at the words on either end of
the dependency
so discussing issues that seems a
reasonable thing to say and so it's
likely that issues
could be the object of discussing
whereas if it was some other word right
if you're thinking of
making you know outstanding the object
of discussion discussing outstanding
that doesn't sound right so that
wouldn't be so good
a second source of information is
distance so most dependencies are
relatively short distance some of them
aren't some of
long distance dependencies but they're
relatively rare the vast majority of
dependencies are nearby
and
another source of information is the
intervening material so there are
certain things that dependencies um
rarely span
so
clauses and sentences
are normally organized around verbs and
so dependencies rarely span across
intervening verbs
we can also use punctuation and written
language things like commas which can
give some indication of the structure
and so punctuation may also indicate bad
places to have
long distance dependencies over
and there's one final source of
information which is what's referred to
as valency which is for a head what kind
of information does it usually have
around it so if you have a noun
there are things that you just know
about what kinds of dependents nouns
normally have so it's common that it
will have a determiner to the left the
cat
on the other hand um
it's
not going to be the case that there's a
determiner to the right cat the that's
just not what you get in english
on the left you're also
likely to have an adjectival modifier
that's where he had cuddly
but again it's not so likely you're
going to have the adjectival modifier
over on the right for cuddly so there
are sort of facts about what things
different kinds of words take on the
left and the right and so that's the
valency of the heads and that's also a
useful source of information
okay
so what do we need to do
using that information
to build a parser well effectively what
we do is have a sentence i'll give a
talk tomorrow on your networks and what
we have to do is say for every word in
that sentence we have to choose some
other word that it's a dependent of
where one possibility is it's a
dependent of root so we're giving it a
structure where we're saying okay for
this word i've decided that it's a
dependent on on networks and then
for this word it's also dependent on
networks um
and for
this word it's a dependent on give
so we're choosing um one for each word
and there are usually a few constraints
so only one word is a dependent of root
we have a tree
we don't want cycles so we don't want to
say that word a is dependent on word b
and word b is dependent on word a
and then there's one final issue um
which is um
whether arrows can cross or not so in in
this particular sentence we actually
have these crossing dependencies you can
see there i'll give a talk tomorrow on
neural networks
and this is the correct dependency parse
for this sentence because what we have
here is that it's a talk and it's a talk
on neural network so the on neural
networks modifies the talk um but which
leads to these crossing dependencies i
didn't have to say it like that i could
have said i'll give a talk on your
networks um tomorrow and then on your
networks would be next to the talk
so most of the time
in languages
dependencies are projective the things
stay together so the dependencies have a
kind of a nesting structure of the kind
that you also see in context-free
grammars but most languages have at
least a few phenomena where you ended up
with these ability for phrases to be
split apart which lead to non-projective
dependencies so in particular
one of them in english is that you can
take modifying phrases and clauses like
the on neural networks here and shift
them right towards the end of the
sentence and get i'll give a talk
tomorrow on neural networks and that
then leads to non-projective sentences
um
so as a parse is projective if there are
no crossing dependency arcs when the
words are laid out in their linear order
with all arcs above the words
and if you have a dependency pass that
corresponds to a context-free grammar
tree um it actually has to be projective
because context-free grammars
necessarily have this sort of nested
tree structure following the linear
order
but dependency grammars normally allow
non-projective structures to account for
displaced
constituents and you can't easily get
the semantics of certain constructions
right without these non-projective
dependencies so here's another example
um in english with question formation
with what's called preposition stranding
so the sentence is who did bill buy the
coffee from yesterday
um there's another way i could have said
this
it's less natural in english but i could
have said um from who did bill
from who did bill buy the coffee
yesterday
in many languages of the world that's
the only way you could have said it and
when you do that
from who
is kept together and you have a
projective pass for the sentence but
english allows and indeed much prefers
you to do what is referred to as
preposition stranding where you move the
who um but you just leave the
preposition behind and so you get who
did bill buy the coffee from yesterday
and so then we're ending up with this
non-projective dependency structure as
i've shown there
okay i'll come back to non-projectivity
in a little bit
how do we go about building
dependency parsers
well there are a whole bunch of ways um
that you can build dependency parsers
very quickly i'll just say a few names
and i'll tell you about one of them so
you can use dynamic programming methods
to build dependency parsers so i i
showed earlier that you can have an
exponential number of parsers for a
sentence and that sounds like really bad
news for building a system well it turns
out that you can be clever and you can
work out a way to dynamic program
finding that exponential number of
parsers and then you can have an o n
cubed algorithm so you could do that
you can use graph algorithms and um and
i'll say a bit about that later but that
may spill into next time um so you can
see
since we're wanting to kind of connect
up all the words into a tree using graph
edges that you could think of doing that
using using a minimum spanning tree
algorithm of the sort that you hopefully
saw in cf cs 161 and so that idea has
been used for parsing
constraint satisfaction ideas that you
might have seen in cs221 have been used
for dependency parsing
but the way i'm going to show now is
transition based parsing or sometimes
referred to as deterministic dependency
parsing and the idea of this is one's
going to use a transition system so
that's like shift reduce parsing if
you've seen shift reduce parsing
in something like a compiler's class or
a formal languages class that shift and
reduce our transition steps and so use a
transition system
to guide the construction of
and so let me just explain about that
so
let's see um so this was an idea
that was made prominent by joachim
nivray who's a swedish
computational linguist
who introduced this idea of greedy
transition based parsing
so his idea is well what we're going to
do for dependency parsing is we're going
to part be able to pass sentences by
having a set of transitions which are
kind of like shift reduce parser and
it's going to just work left to right
bottom up and pass a sentence so we're
going to say we have a stack sigma
a buffer beta of the words that we have
to process and we're going to build up a
set of dependency arcs by using actions
which are shift and reduce actions and
putting those together this will give us
the ability to put path structures over
sentences
and let me go through the details of
this
and this is a little bit hairy
when you first see it that's not so
complex really and
this this kind of
transition based dependency parser is
what we'll use in assignment three so
what we have so this is our transition
system we have a starting point where we
start with a stack that just has the
root symbol on it and a buffer that has
the sentence that's about to part we're
about to pass and so far we haven't
built any
dependency arcs and so at each point in
time we can choose one of three actions
we can shift which moves the next word
onto the stack
we can then do actions that are the
reduce actions so two reduce actions to
make it a dependency grammar we can
either do a left arc reduce or a right
arc reduce so when we do
either of those we take the top two
items on the stack
and we make one of them
a dependent of the other one so we can
either say okay let's make wi a
dependent of wj or else we can say okay
let's make wj a dependent of wi and so
the result of when we do that is the one
that's the dependent
disappears from the stack and so in the
stacks over here there's one less item
but then we add a dependency r to our
arc set so that we say that we've got
either a dependency from j to i or a
dependency from i to j
and commonly when we do this we actually
also specify what grammatical relation
connects the two such as subject object
noun modifier and so we also have here a
relation
that's still probably still very
abstract so let's go through an example
so this is how a simple
transition based dependency parser
what's referred to as an arc standard
transition based dependency parser would
pass up i ate the fish so remember these
are the different operations that we can
apply so to start off with we have root
on the stack and the sentence in the
buffer and we have no dependency arcs
constructed so we have to choose one of
the three actions and when there's only
one thing on the stack the only thing we
can do is shift so we shift
and now the stack looks like this so now
we have to take another action and at
this point we have a choice because we
could immediately reduce
so you know we could say okay let's just
make
i a dependent of root and we'd get
a stack size of one again but that'd be
the wrong thing to do
because i isn't um the head of the
sentence so what we should instead do is
shift again and get i8 on the stack and
fish still in the buffer
well at that point we keep on passing a
bit further and so now what we can do is
say well wait a minute now
i is a dependent of 8 and so
we can do a left arc reduce and so i
disappears from the stack so here's our
new stack but we add to the set of arcs
that we've added that i is the subject
of eight
okay well after that
we could have we could reduce again
because there's still two things on the
stack but that would be the wrong thing
to do the right thing to do next would
be to
shift
fish onto the stack and then at that
point we can do a right arc reduce
saying that eight is
the object of fish and add a new
dependency to our dependency set
and then
we can one more time
do a right arc reduce
to say that 8 is the root of the whole
sentence and add in that extra root
relation with our pseudo root and at
that point we've reached the end
condition so the end condition was the
buffer was empty
and there's one thing the root on the
stack and at that point we can finish
so this little transition machine does
the parsing up of the sentence
but there's one thing that's left to
explain still here
which is how do you choose the next
action so as soon as you have two things
or more on the stack what you do next
you've always got a choice you could
keep shifting at least if there's still
things on the buffer or you can do a
left arc or you can do a right arc
and how do you know what choice is
correct and well one answer to that is
to say well you don't know what choice
is correct and that's why parsing is
hard and sentences are ambiguous you can
do any of those things you have to
explore all of them and well if you
naively explore all of them then you do
an exponential amount of work to pass
the sentence
so
in
the
early 2000s um
joachim phrase and you know that's
essentially what people have done in the
80s and 90s is explore every path um but
um in the early 2000s um joachim
neverey's essential observation was but
wait a minute we know about machine
learning now so why don't i try and
train a classifier which predicts
what the next action i should take is
given this stack and buffer
configuration
because if i can write
a machine learning classifier
which can nearly always correctly
predict um the next action given a stack
and buffer
then i'm in a really good position
because then i can build what's referred
to as a greedy dependency parser which
just goes bang bang bang word at a time
okay here's the next thing
run classifier choose next action run
classifier choose next action run
classifier choose next action so that
the amount of work that we're doing
becomes linear in the length of the
sentence rather than that being
cubic and the length of the sentence
using dynamic programming or exponential
and the length of the sentence if you
don't use dynamic programming
so for each at each step we predict the
next action using some discriminative
classifier so starting off he was using
things like support vector machines
but it can be anything at all like a
soft max classifier that's closer to our
neural networks and there are either for
what i presented um three classes if
you're just thinking of the two reduces
and the shift or if you're thinking of
you're also assigning a relation and you
have a set of r
relations like 20 relations then that's
the sort of 41 moves that you could um
decide on at each point and the features
are effectively the configurations i was
showing before what's the top of the
stack word what part of speech is it
what's the first word in the buffer
what's that words part of speech etc and
so on the simplest way of doing this
you're now doing no search at all you
just sort of take each configuration and
turn decide the most likely next move
and you make it and that's a greedy
dependency parser which is widely used
you can do better if you want to do a
lot more work so you can do what's
called a beam search where you maintain
a number of fairly good parse prefixes
at each step
and you can extend them out further and
then you can evaluate later on which of
those seems to be the best
and so beam search is one technique to
improve dependency parsing by doing a
lot of work
and it turns out that although
these greedy transition based parses
are a fraction worse than the best
possible ways known to pass sentences um
but they actually work very accurately
almost as well and they have this
wonderful advantage that they give you
linear time parsing in terms of the
length of your sentences and text and so
if you want to do a huge amount of
parsing
they're just a fantastic thing to use
because um
you've then got an algorithm that scales
to the size of the web
okay um
so
i'm kind of a little bit behind so i
guess i'm not going to get through all
of these slides today and we'll have to
finish out the final slides tomorrow but
um just to push a teeny bit further i'll
just say a couple more on the sort of
what never did for
dependency parser and then i'll sort of
introduce the neural form of that in the
next class so conventionally you had
this sort of stack and buffer
configuration and you wanted to build a
machine learning classifier and so the
way that was done was by using
symbolic features of this configuration
and what kind of
symbolic features did you use you use
these indicator features that picked out
a small subset normally one to three
elements of the configuration so you'd
have a feature that could be something
like
the thing on the top of the stack is the
word good which is an adjective
or it could be the thing on the top of
the stack is an adjective and the thing
that's first in the buffer is a noun
or it could just be looking at one thing
and saying the first thing in the buffer
is a verb
so you'd have all of these features and
because these features commonly involved
words
and commonly involved conjunctions of
several conditions
you have a lot of features
and you know having
mentions of words and conjunctions and
conditions definitely help to make these
parsers work better
but
nevertheless because you had all of
these sort of one zero symbolic features
that you had a ton of such features so
commonly these parsers were built um
using something like you know a million
to ten million different features of
sentences
and i mentioned already the importance
of evaluation let me just sort of
quickly say
how these parsers were evaluated
so
to evaluate a
a parser for a particular sentence it
was hand
our test set was hand passed in the tree
bank so we have gold dependencies of
what the human thought were right and so
we can write those down
those dependencies down as statements of
saying
the first word is the dependent of the
second word fire a subject dependency
and then the parser is also going to
make similar claims as to what's
dependent on what and so there are two
common metrics that are used one is just
are you getting these dependency facts
right so both of these dependency facts
match and so that's
referred to as the unlabeled accuracy
score where we're just sort of measuring
accuracies which are of all of the
dependencies
in the gold sentence and remember we
have one dependency per word in the
sentence so here we have five
how many of them are correct and that's
our unlabeled accuracy score of eighty
percent but a slightly more um rigorous
evaluation is to say well no we're also
going to label them and we're going to
say that this is the subject
that's actually called the root this
one's the object
so these dependencies
have labels
and you also need to get the grammatical
relation label right and so that's then
referred to as labeled accuracy score
and
although i got those two right for that
as
i guess according to this example
actually this is wrong it looks like i
got
oh no this is wrong there sorry that
one's wrong there okay um so i only got
two of the um dependencies correct in
the sense that i both got what depends
on what and the label correct and so my
labeled accuracy score is only 40
percent
okay um so i'll stop there now for the
introduction for dependency parsing and
i still have an iou which is um how we
can then bring neural nets into this
picture and how they can um be used to
improve dependency parsing so i'll do
that at the start of next time before
then proceeding further
into
neural language models